The Joe Rogan experience. Um,
are you aware at all of the current
state of surveillance and what,
if anything has changed
since your revelations?
Yeah, I mean the, the big thing
that's changed, um, since I was,
uh, in, in, in, in 2013
is now it's mobile first.
Everything, um, mobile
was still a big deal,
right? Um, and the intelligence
community was very much grappling, uh,
to, to get its hands around
it and to deal with it. Um,
but now people are much less likely
to use laptop than use a desktop than,
than yours. You know, God,
any kind of wired phone. Um,
then they already use a smartphone. Uh,
and both Apple and Android
devices unfortunately, uh,
are not especially good in protecting
your privacy. You think right now,
um, you've got a smart phone, right?
You might be listening to this on a
train somewhere and in traffic right now.
Um, or are you Joe right now? You got a
phone somewhere in the room, right? Uh,
the phone is turned off for at
least the screen is turned off.
It's sitting there. It is powered on.
And if somebody sends you a message,
the screen Burl blinks to
life, how does that happen?
Right? Uh, how is it that if someone
from any corner of the earth, uh,
dials a number, your phone
rings and nobody else's rings,
how is it that you can dial anybody
else's number and only their phone rings?
Right? Uh, every smartphone,
every phone at all, uh,
is constantly connected, uh, to the
nearest cellular tower. Um, every phone,
even when the screen is off,
you think it's doing nothing.
You can't see it because radio
frequency emissions are invisible. Um,
it's screaming in the air
saying, here I am, here I am.
Here is my a IME. I think it's
a individual manufacturers,
equipment identity, uh, and
IME high, uh, individual, uh,
manufacturers, um, subscriber
identity. I could be wrong on the,
the breakout there, but the, the
acronyms are the IME I and the IMSI.
And you can search for these things.
There are two global unique identifiers
that only exist anywhere in the world,
uh, in one place. Right?
This makes your phone different
than all the other phones. Uh,
the IMEA is burned into
the handset of your phone,
no matter what SIM card you change
to, it's always going to be the same.
And it's always going to be
telling the phone network.
It's this physical handset. Then the IME,
SSI is in your SIM card. Right? And this
is what holds your phone number, right?
Is that basically the key, the
right to use that phone number.
And so your phone is sitting there
doing nothing, you think? Uh,
but it's constantly shouting and
saying, I'm here who is closest to me.
That's a cell phone tower and every
cell phone tower with its ears,
uh, is listening for these little
cries for help and going, Oh right,
I see Joe Rogan's phone.
Right? I see Jamie's phone,
I see all these phones
that are here right now.
And it compares notes,
uh, with the other, uh,
network towers and your smartphone
compares notes with them to go,
who do I hear the loudest
and who you hear, uh,
the loudest is a proxy for, uh,
proximity for closeness. Distance,
right. They go, whoever I hear more loudly
than anybody else that's close to me.
So you're going to be bound to this cell
phone tower and that cell phone tower
is going to make a note, a permanent
record, uh, saying this phone,
uh,
this phone handset with this phone
number at this time was connected to me.
Right? And based on your phone
handset and your phone number, uh,
they can get your identity right. Um,
because you pay for this stuff with your
credit card and everything like that.
Uh, and even if you don't, right,
it's still active at your house, uh,
overnight. It's still active, you know,
on your nightstand when you're sleeping,
it's still whatever, uh,
the movements of your phone or
the movements of you as a person.
And those are often, uh, quite uniquely
identifying. It goes to your home,
it goes to your workplace. Other
people don't have it, sorry. Um,
and a new way. It's
constantly shouting this out.
And then a compares notes with
the other, uh, parts and network.
And when somebody is trying to get to a
phone, it compares notes of the network,
compares notes to go,
where is this phone with this phone
number in the world right now?
And to that cell phone tower
that is closest to that phone,
it sends out a signal saying,
we have a call for you,
make your phone start ringing so your
owner can answer it and then it connects
it across this whole path.
But what this means is that
whenever you're carrying a phone,
whenever the phone is turned on,
there's a record of your presence at
that place that is being made and created
by companies. It does not need
to be kept forever. And in fact,
there's no good argument
for it to be kept forever.
But these companies see that
as valuable information, right?
This is the whole big data problem that
we're running into and all this, uh,
information that used
to be a femoral, right?
Where were you when you were eight
years old? You know, um, where were you?
Where'd you go after you
had a bad breakup? You know,
who did you spend the night with?
Who'd you call after all this
information used to be a femoral,
meaning it disappeared, right? Like,
like the morning Dew. It would be gone.
No one would remember it. But
now these things are stored.
Now these things are saved. It,
it doesn't matter whether
you're doing anything wrong,
it doesn't matter whether you even
most ordinary person on earth, uh,
because that's how bulk collection,
which is the government's euphemism
for mass surveillance works.
They simply collect it all in advance
in hopes that one day it will become
useful.
And that was just talking about how
you connect to the phone network.
That's not talking about all those apps
on your phone that are contacting the
network even more frequently. Right? Uh,
how do you get a text
message notification?
How do you get an email notification?
How is it the Facebook knows where
you're at? You know, all of these things,
these analytics, uh,
they are trying to keep track through
location services on your phone,
through GPS,
through even just what wireless access
points you're connected to because
there's a global constantly
updated map. There's actually,
many of them have wireless access
points in the world because just like we
talked about, every phone has a unique
identifier that's globally unique.
Every wireless access point in the world,
right? You cable modem at home, uh,
whether it's in your laptop,
every device that has a radio modem
has a globally unique identifier in it.
Um, and uh, this is standard
term. You can look it up. Uh,
and these things can be mapped when
they're broadcasting in the air because
again, like your phone says to the
cellphone tower, I have this identifier.
The cell phone tower responds
and says, I have this identifier.
And anybody who's listening, uh,
they can write these things down.
And all those Google street view
cars that go back and forth, right?
They're keeping notes on whose
wifi is active on this block,
right? And then they build a new giant
map. So even if you have GPS turned off,
right, uh, as long as you're connected
to wifi, uh, those apps can go,
well, I, I'm connected to Joe's wifi,
but I can also see his neighbor's wifi
here and the other one in this apartment
over here and the other
one in the apartment here.
And you should only be able to hear
those four globally unique wifi access
points from these points
in physical space. Right.
The intersection in between the
spreads, the domes of all those,
uh, wireless access points.
It's a proxy for location and
it just goes on and on and on.
We could talk about this for four more
hours. We don't have that kind of time.
Can I ask you this? Is there a way to
mitigate any of this personally? I mean,
mean even shutting your phone off doesn't
even work, right? Well, so it, it, it,
it does in a way. It's yes and no. Um,
the thing was shutting your phone off
that as a risk is how do you know your
phone is actually turned off?
Um, [inaudible] used to be a, a,
when I was in Geneva, for example,
uh, working for the CIA. Um,
we would all carry like drug
dealer phones, uh, you know,
the old smartphones, the, or, sorry, old
dumb phones. They're not smart phones.
And the reason why was just because they
had removed from the backs where you
could take the battery out. Right.
And the one beautiful thing
about technology is if
there's no electricity in it,
right? If there's, there's no
gold juice available to it.
If there's no battery connected to it,
it's not sending anything because
you have to get power from somewhere.
You have to have power
in order to do work. Um,
but now your phones are all sealed,
right? He can't take the batteries out.
So there are potential ways that you
can hack a phone where it appears to be
off, but it's not actually off.
It's just pretending to be off.
Whereas in fact it's still listening
in and doing all this stuff.
But for the average person
that doesn't apply. Right.
And I got to tell you guys, they've
been chasing me all over the place.
I don't worry about that stuff. Right. Um,
and it's because if they are applying
that level of effort to me, uh,
they'll probably get the same
information through other routes. Um,
I am as careful as I can and I
use things like fair to cages.
I turn devices off, but
if they're actually, uh,
manipulating the way devices display, um,
it's just too great a level of effort
even for someone like me to keep that up
on a constant basis.
Also. Um, if they get me,
I only trust phones so much.
So there's only so much they
can derive from the compromise.
And this is how operational
security works. Uh,
you think about what are the realistic
threats that you're facing that you're
trying to mitigate and the mitigation
that you're trying to do is what would be
the loss? What would be the damage done
to you if this stuff was exploited?
Much more realistic than worrying about
these things that I call voodoo hacks,
right? Which are like next level stuff.
And actually just a shout out for those
of your readers who are interested in
this stuff. I wrote a paper
on this specific problem.
How do you know when a
phone is actually off?
How do you know when it's actually not
spying on you? Uh, with a brilliant,
brilliant guy named, uh, Andrew Bunnie
Quang, uh, he's an MIT PhD and I,
I think electrical engineering, um, uh,
called the introspection engine, uh,
that was published in the journal of
open engineering. You can find it online.
Um, and it'll go as deep down in the
weeds. I promise you as you want.
We take an iPhone six, uh,
this was back when it was fairly new
and we modified it so we could actually,
uh, not trust the device,
uh, to report its own state,
but physically monitor it state
to see if it was spying on you.
But for average people, right?
Uh, this sack endemic, uh,
that's not your primary threat.
Your primary threats are these
bulk collection programs.
Your primary threat is the fact that your
phone is constantly squawking to these
cell phone towers is doing all of these
things because we leave our phones in a
state that is constantly on.
You're constantly connected, right?
Airplane mode a doesn't even
turn off wifi really anymore,
just turns off the cellular modem. Um,
but the whole idea is we
need to identify the problem.
And the central problem with smart phone
use today is you have no idea what the
hell it's doing at any given time.
Like the phone has the screen off,
you don't know what it's connected to.
You don't know how
frequently it's doing it. Uh,
Apple and iOS unfortunately makes it
impossible to see what kind of network
connections are constantly made on the
device and to intermediate them going,
I don't want Facebook to be able
to talk right now. You know,
I don't want Google to be able to
talk right now. I just want my,
a secure messenger app to be able to talk.
I just want my weather
app to be able to talk,
but I just checked my weather
and now I'm done with it.
So I don't want that to
be able to talk anymore.
And we need to be able
to make these intelligent
decisions on not just an app by
app basis, but a connection by
connection basis. Right? You want,
let's say you use
Facebook because you know,
for whatever judgment we have,
a lot of people might do it.
You want it to be able to connect
to Facebook's content servers. Uh,
you want to be able to message a friend.
Do you want to be able to
download a photograph or whatever,
but you don't want it to be
able to talk to an ad server.
You don't want it to talk to an analytics
server that that's monitoring your
behavior, right?
You don't want to talk to all these
third party things because Facebook crams
their garbage and almost every app that
you download and you don't even know
what's happening because
you can't see it. Right?
And this is the problem with the data
collection used today is there is an
industry that is built on
keeping this invisible.
And what we need to do is we need to
make the activities of our devices,
whether it's a phone, whether
it's computer, whatever, uh,
more visible and understandable to the
average person and then give them control
over it.
So like if you could see your phone
right now and at the very center of his,
a little green icon, that's your
handset or it's a picture of your face,
whatever. And then you see all these
little spokes coming off of it.
That's every app that your phone is
talking to right now or every app that is
active on your phone right now and
all the hosts that it's connecting to.
And you can see right now wants every
three seconds your phone is checking into
Facebook and you could just
poke that app and then boom,
it's not talking to Facebook
anymore. Facebook's not allowed.
Facebook speaking privileges have been
revoked. Right? You would do that.
We would all do that. If there was
a button on your phone that said,
do what I want but not spy on me,
you would press that button. Right?
That button is not, uh, does not exist
right now. And both Google and Apple,
unfortunately Apple's a lot better
at this than Google. Uh, but uh,
neither of them allow that
button to exist. In fact,
they actively interfere with it because
they say it's a security risk and from a
particular perspective, they, they
actually aren't wrong there. Um,
but it's not enough to go, you know,
we have to lock that capability off
from people because we don't trust they
would make the right decisions.
We think it's too complicated
for people to do this.
We think there's too many
connections being made.
Well that is actually a confession
of the problem right there.
If you think people can't understand it,
if you think there are too
many communications happening,
if you think there's too much complexity
in there, it needs to be simplified.
Just like the president can't
control everything like that.
If you have to be the president of the
phone and the phone is as complex as the
United States government,
we have a problem guys,
this should be a much more simple process.
It should be obvious and
the fact that it's not.
And the fact we read story after story
year after year saying all your data's
been breached here, uh, this
company's spying on you.
Here is companies manipulating your
purchases or would your search results or
they're hiding these things from your
timeline or they're influencing you or
manipulating and all of these different
ways that happens as a result of a
single, uh, problem.
And that problem is in any
equality of available information.
They can see everything about you.
They can see everything about what your
device is doing and they can do whatever
they want with your device. You on the
other hand, owned the device. Well,
rather you paid for the device.
But increasingly these
corporations own it. Increasingly,
these governments own it,
and increasingly we are living in a
world where we do all the work, right?
We pay all the taxes, we
pay all the costs, uh,
but we own less and less,
and nobody understands this better
than the youngest generation.
Well,
it seems like our data became a commodity
before we understood what it was.
It became this thing that's insanely
valuable to Google and Facebook and all
these social media platforms. Before
we understood what we were giving up,
they were making billions of dollars,
and then once that money is being earned,
and once everyone's
accustomed to this situation,
it's very difficult to
pull the reigns back.
It's very difficult to turn that horse
around precisely because the money then
becomes pout. Right? Right. The
information then becomes influence.
That also seems to be the same sort of
situation that would happen with these
mass surveillance States
once they have the access,
it's going to be incredibly difficult
for them to relinquish that.
All right. Yeah. No, you're,
you're exactly correct.
And this is the subject
of the book. I mean this,
this is the permanent record
and this is where it came from.
This is how it came to exist. Um,
the story of our lifetimes is
how intentionally by design,
uh, a number of institutions, uh,
both governmental and corporate, uh,
realized it was in their mutual interest
to conceal their data collection
activities to increase, uh,
the breadth and depth of their sensor
networks that were sort of spread out
through society. Remember back in
the day intelligence collection, uh,
in the United States, even at Sagan
used to mean sending an FBI agent,
right to put alligator clips on an
embassy building or sending in a,
somebody disguised as,
as a Workman and they put a bug in a
building or they built a satellite,
uh, listening site, right? We,
we called these foreign set or
foreign satellite collection. Uh,
we're out on the desert somewhere. They
built a big, uh, parabolic collector,
um, and it's just listening
to satellite emissions, right?
These satellite emissions, the satellite
links were owned by militaries.
They were exclusive to governments,
right? It wasn't everybody broadly.
Also valence was targeted
because it had to be,
what changed with technology is
that surveillance could now become
indiscriminate. It could become a
Dragnet. It could become bulk collection,
which should become one of the
dirtiest phrases in the language. Uh,
if we have any kind of decency.
Uh, but we were intentionally,
um, this was intentionally concealed from
us. Right? Uh, the government did it,
they used classification.
Um, companies did it. Uh,
they intentionally didn't talk
about it. They denied, uh,
these things were going,
they, they said, uh,
you agreed to this and you didn't agree
to nothing like this. I'm, I'm sorry.
Right. They go, we put that terms of
service page up and you clicked it.
You clicked a button that said, I agree.
Because you were trying to open an
account so you could talk to your friends.
You were trying to get driving directions.
You were trying to get an email account.
You weren't trying to agree to
some 600 page legal form. Uh, the,
even if you read, you wouldn't
understand and it doesn't matter.
Even if you did understand, because one
of the very first paragraphs in it said,
disagreement can be changed at any time
unilaterally without your consent by the
company. Right. Uh,
they have built a legal paradigm that
presumes records collected about us do not
belong to us.
This is a sort of one of
the core principles on which
mass surveillance from the
government's perspective in
the United States is legal.
And you have to understand that all
this stuff we talked about today,
government says everything they do is
legal right. And they go, so it's fine.
Our perspective as a
public should be, we'll,
that's actually the problem
because this isn't okay.
The scandal isn't how
they're breaking the law.
The scandals that they don't have to
break the law and the way they say they're
not breaking the law is something
called the third party doctrine.
A third party doctrine is a
legal principle and derive from a
case. And I believe the 1970s, uh,
called Smith vs Maryland, um,
and Smith was this knucklehead, uh, who
was harassing this lady, making, uh,
phone calls, uh, to her house. Uh,
and when she would pick up, he just,
I don't know who sit there,
heavy breathing, whatever,
like a classic creeper.
Um, and, you know, it was terrifying.
This poor lady. So she calls the cops,
uh, and says,
one day I got one of these phone calls
and then I see this car creeping past my
house on the street and she
got a license plate number.
So she goes to the cops and she goes,
is this the guy and the cops, again,
they're trying to do a good thing
here. Uh, they look up his, uh,
license plate number, uh, and they find
out where this guy is. And then they go,
well, what phone number is
registered to that house?
And they go to the phone company and
they say, can you give us this record?
And the phone company says, yeah, sure.
And it's the guy the cops got there,
man. Right. Huh. So they go
arrest guy. And then in court, uh,
his lawyer brings all this
stuff up and they go, um,
[inaudible] you did this without a
warrant. Uh, that was, sorry, that was,
that was the, the,
the problem was they went to the phone
company that got the records without a
warrant. They just asked for it
or they subpoenaed it, right?
Some lower standard of legal review and
the company gave it to them and got the
guy they Marchmont in jail. Uh,
and they could have gotten a warrant,
right? But it was just expedience.
They just didn't want to take
the time in small town cops,
you can understand how it happens.
They know the guy's a creeper.
They just want to get him off to jail. Um,
and so they made a mistake with the
government doesn't want to let go.
They fight on this and
they go, uh, [inaudible].
It wasn't actually, they
weren't his records.
And so because they didn't belong to him,
he didn't have a fourth
amendment right. Uh,
to demand a warrant be issued for them.
They were the company's records and the
company provided them voluntarily and
hence,
no warrant was required because you can
give whatever you want without a warrant
as long as it's yours.
Now, here's the problem.
The government extrapolated a principle
in a single case of a single known,
suspected criminal who had,
they had real good reasons
to suspect was their guy.
Um,
and use that to go to a company and
get records from them and establish a
precedent that these records
don't belong to the guy. Uh,
they belong to the company.
And then they said, well,
if one person doesn't have a fourth
amendment interest in records held by a
company, no one does.
And so the company then has absolute
proprietary ownership of all of these
records about all of our lives. And
remember, this is back in the 1970s,
you know, the internet hardly exists in
these kinds of contexts. Smartphones,
you know, don't exist. Modern society,
modern communications don't exist.
This is the very beginning
of the technological era. Uh,
and flash forward now 40 years,
uh,
and they are still relying on this
precedent about this one. You know,
perfect creeper to go.
Nobody has a privacy right for
anything that's held by a company.
And so long as they do that,
companies are going to be extraordinarily
powerful and they're going to be
extraordinarily abusive. And this is
something that people don't get. They go,
Oh, well, it's data collection,
right? They're exploiting data. Uh,
this is data about human lives.
Uh, it is state about people.
These records are about you. It's
not data that's being exploited. Uh,
it's people that are being
exploited. It's not, um,
data that's being manipulated.
It's you that's being,
uh, manipulated. And this, this is a,
this is something that I think a lot of
people are beginning to understand. Now,
the problem is the companies and the
governments are still pretending,
don't understand or disagreeing
with this. And this is wrong.
My ends me of something that, uh, one of
my old friends, uh, John Perry Barlow,
um, who served with me, uh,
at the freedom of the press foundation
on the president of the board, uh,
used to say to me, um, which is a,
you can't awaken someone
who's pretending to be asleep.
[inaudible].